Bagavat
sambudan
[Música]
gми
saran
[Música]
Sang
saran
[Música]
pian
saranan
[Música]
link.
Eh,
[Música]
do
ச
[Música]
E
গোসাগва
[Música]
сама
сам
[Música]
Schre
маون
[Música]
Candr
S
guru
pig
[Música]
Машин
Cronus
[Música]
Gelma
de
honra.
Tá com delay? Não tá isso. Deixa eu
pensar. Aquele som vem da internet.
Ele é direto daqui. Como é que pode ter
delay?
Acho que é melhor baixar um pouco para
não interferir, né?
[Música]
C du candr
Gra
[Música]
Grup
grupe
de
honra romar
grup.
[Música]
Grup
honra
Grupar
grup
[Música]
honra rzar
honra
gurup.
[Música]
Hrazará
honra
gur
[Música]
honra
gurup
[Música]
honra.
Grup
honra benzar
honra
[Música]
Grup
honra
[Música]
Grup
honra
[Música]
grup.
Hz
grup
honra
grup.
[Música]
Honra
grup
[Música]
honra
grupar
[Música]
Grup
honra
grup
[Música]
honra
Grup
[Música]
honra romar
grup
de
[Música]
para
temparação.
[Música]
Parage.
Parag
[Música]
tempar
sang
[Música]
Paraga,
tem
[Música]
Paraga
tempar
sang
[Música]
de
Paraga,
[Música]
tem
s.
[Música]
para
tempar
sangте
[Música]
Sang
band
[Música]
para sangat
band
Sag
[Música]
templar
sang
tempo
de
sorra.
[Música]
para sangra
Paragate
[Música]
para sang
de sra
[Música]
para sangat
parante.
[Música]
Tempar
Sang
[Música]
para
tempar
[Música]
sangat
para
[Música]
sangar
para
[Música]
Eh,
soтера
[Música]
Sanga
tempo.
[Música]
Gate.
para
sangar
de sate
[Música]
parang
Sang
band
[Música]
paragса.
Bra
[Música]
tempa
Paraga,
[Música]
tem
de s.
[Música]
para
tempar
sangте
[Música]
Ага.
at
[Música]
Soте
para
[Música]
tempar
sang
[Música]
para
tempar
[Música]
sangat.
para
[Música]
sangat
bingте
[Música]
para
tempar
sangat
[Música]
Tempanga
temга
[Música]
sang
paraга
[Música]
para
tempar
sang
[Música]
para página 20.
Através de homenagens, oferendas,
confissão, regozijo, solicitação e
súplica. Qualquer pequeno mérito que eu
tenha gerado, dedico a que todos possam
alcançar a iluminação.
A terra está ungida com água perfumada,
espargida de flores e adornadas pelo
sumero, os quatro continentes, o sol e a
lua. Por eu ter imaginado e oferecido
isso como um reino búdico, possam todos
os seres usufruir dos reinos puros. A
terra está ungida com água perfumada,
espargida de flores e adornada pelo
Sumero, os quatro continentes, o sol e a
lua. Por eu ter imaginado e oferecido
isso como um reino búdico, possam todos
os seres usufruir dos reinos puros. A
terra está ungida com água perfumada,
espargida de flores e adornada pelo
Sumero, os quatro continentes, o sol e a
lua. Por eu ter imaginado e oferecido
isso como um reino búdico, possam todos
os seres usufruir dos reinos puros.
Hidan, Guru Ratna, Mandala, Canía,
Tayame.
Para satisfazer as necessidades de todos
os seres em níveis de compreensão,
solicitamos a você que gire a roda do
dharma, incluindo as abordagens menores
e maiores, comuns e extraordinárias.
Através desse mérito, que todos os seres
possam se tornar oniscientes e alcançar
o estado búdico, derrotando todas as
faltas e impedimentos.
Que todos os seres possam ser liberados
do oceano da existência condicionada,
agitado pelas ondas do nascimento, da
velice, da doença e da morte.
Bom dia,
esse aqui pode ser, pode ser isso.
Nós ficamos sem som.
Mesa, nós estamos sem som.
tá com delay, né? Mas igual tipo assim
>> melhora, né?
>> Ah, mas perde,
>> mas eu p no outro no outro canal.
Deixa lovação agora. Vou resolver o DB.
É meso
>> pegar aqui uma faixa vermelha só para
ver. Oi. Oi. Essas coisas mexer
>> já tá, né?
Caixa só para ver. Pode por ampor, eu
não consigo achar que isso já.
>> Como é que você vai ligar ela?
tirar o quê?
Um P 10 P 10
>> é
tudo bem. Vamos pegar para
[Música]
assim. Pode para dentro.
อ
E todo mundo vai ter que ouvir duas
vezes
aí.
Ai meu Deus.
>> Como? Eu acho que dá para ir baixando
assim, né? Se
ou então vamos experimentar, tirar.
Vamos ver se a Sibell ouve.
Eu
acho melhor.
Vocês estão ouvindo aí no Zoom, pessoal?
Tão tão ouvindo?
Pessoal do Darmata tá ouvindo.
Oh,
vocês não tão com frio aí, com pouca
roupa pessoal?
[Risadas]
Hoje, hoje é um dia de Bacupari,
pessoal. Um super vento aqui com uma
chuvinha.
Cada um que chegou aqui achou que
conseguiu vencer, não sabe como a
estrada. Assim,
é bonito se ver.
Nós estamos com problema na sala aqui
dentro que dá um delay.
Então o som da sala tá com delay. Então
nós estamos desligando o som da sala. Tá
todo mundo sentando aqui na volta.
para não precisar do som na sala.
E tu tá bem, Helen? Tudo bem aí?
Que bom.
A gente não te ouve, mas tudo bem.
Quando a Rafa trabalha sozinha, tudo
bem, mas o Bruno tá ali do lado para
atrapalhar, melhor coisa. Não,
>> tá ouvindo agora, Lama?
>> Vamos botar, vamos botar pressão no
Bruno.
Eu acho que tem que botar o Renato ali
para
>> Vamos botar pressão.
O Sansara é vivo, pessoal. Começa a
falar assim, começa todo mundo passar a
mão
agora tá bonita.
E a Camila tá bem, Camilã,
que bom.
Esse retiro aqui vocês estão ouvindo? Tá
ouvindo aí atrás?
Esse retiro ele é a etapa de meditação,
né?
Então, a gente tem as etapas de visão,
meditação, ação, fluição. Aqui estaria
nessas etapas de meditação
e ação, fruição. Nós estamos nesse nesse
ponto, né? Então, esses dias no caminho
do meio a gente olhou a parte de de
visão,
mas eu vou retornar. Essas partes elas
estão
sempre retornando, né?
A parte de visão, a gente tem seguido ah
o texto iluminação da sabedoria
primordial, que ele dá a estrutura toda,
né?
E
então a gente poderia
eh
olhar desse modo, né? Então a gente aqui
nós vamos olhar o que que a gente faz no
retiro, né? Que que acontece dentro do
retiro.
E eu vou seguir esse
esse roteiro do Anapassat do Satipatana,
eh,
que a gente elege temas para contemplar.
E essa contemplação dos temas já é
vipassa né?
E mas ainda assim nós podemos eh começar
com o chamata,
né, que é uma etapa preliminar. Então
durante esses dias, no caminho do meio,
a gente nós olhamos isso com cuidado.
Vocês continuam ouvindo, tá direito aí?
Tá.
Então, a gente olhou isso com cuidado.
E
como que chamata
eh vai abrir, vai criar a base para que
a visão possa acontecer, né?
E como que a moralidade abre a base para
que chamata aconteça e depois chamata
acontecendo,
ela abre a base paraa visão
e como a visão se distingue de chamata e
se aproxima da mente livre de
características.
Então, nós estamos olhando essas
palavras é que fazem sentido naquilo que
nós estamos trabalhando aqui. Elas são a
linguagem pra gente poder lidar, né?
Então, nós temos
ah, o obstáculo
central paraa entrada na visão é a
originação dependente, que é descrita
como azrava.
Por que que isso ocorre? Porque tão
pronto nós distinguimos algo,
seja pela mente ou pelas consciências
associadas a olhos, ouvidos, nariz,
língua e tato. Tão pronto a gente faz
isso, surgem dois caminhos.
Essa essa bifurcação, ela tá descrita no
próprio sutra surangama.
Então o Buda vai dizer: "Existe o
caminho externalizador, existe o caminho
internalizador.
O caminho externalizador aí, se vocês
olharem com cuidado, é essencialmente o
caminho da originação dependente, que o
Buda vai explicar como uma crescente
complex, uma complex,
uma complexidade crescente, né, uma
expansão, uma multiplicidade
e o caminho internalizador como uma
tendência a uma unidade.
que vai ser reconhecida como o caminho
externalizador é a originação
dependente. Ou seja, eu bato o olho em
algo, distingo algo, eu começo a
produzir outras imagens e outras imagens
que servem de base para produzir outras
imagens aquila sem fim, que vai
constituir o sansara como ele tá
estabelecido.
Por outro lado, existe o caminho
tenalizador, que o Buda vai dizer que é
o caminho de todos os budas,
que é o caminho no qual nós olhamos as
aparências e a gente se pergunta como
que elas surgem,
como que isso surge? E nós percebemos
também que essas aparências elas surgem
e cessam.
Enquanto nós geramos uma intimidade
nesse processo de que as aparências
surgem e cessam,
nós já estamos praticando
chamata.
Então essa intimidade
com a experiência, com a aspiração de
nós ficarmos estáveis,
sem dar sem produzir essa proliferação
de pensamentos, de ações, de
iniciativas,
nós ficamos estáveis,
mas vemos que isso de vez em quando se
perde ou muitas vezes se perde,
mas isso se perde, nós retornamos.
Então, progressivamente nós
desenvolvemos uma familiaridade
com aquilo que tá na base, que é essa
abertura
ao qual nós sempre retornamos.
Então, nós reconhecemos que as
aparências quando elas surgem, elas
surgem como demônios, interferências
fantasmagóricas,
espíritos despeitados e malévolos.
Nós vamos entender que as aparências
mentais que vão surgindo e cessando,
elas têm um poder de direcionar
um processo criativo que vai produzindo
significados encadeados.
Mas não importa quão longos sejam esses
significados encadeados e visões, eles
de repente eles esfumaçam e perdem o
sentido.
Aí nós recuperamos a prática, a gente
volta ao estado livre. Então,
progressivamente
nós geramos uma familiaridade com aquilo
que nós vamos descrever como a mente
livre de características.
Então, essa mente livre de
características, ela é um estado
particular.
Eu posso ter a mente livre de
características e posso ter a mente com
muitos pensamentos, muitas imagens.
E quando eu tô praticando chamata,
eu tenho a tendência a entender que
quando eu não tenho os pensamentos, eu
tô praticando direito. E quando eu tenho
os pensamentos, eu tenho um problema.
Esse
essa visão nessa etapa do caminho, ela é
correta.
Porque nós estamos fazendo um caminho.
Então, por enquanto, eu eu tô
demonizando todos os pensamentos,
demônios interferências
fantasmagóricas, espíritos e malévolas,
mas depois eu vou iluminar os
pensamentos
sem o que eu não tenho a possibilidade
de a liberação.
Se eu não conseguir
iluminar o silêncio e iluminar os
pensamentos,
eu tô condenado a lutar eternamente
contra aparências de um tipo e de outro.
Então, nós vamos convergir em direção à
natural perfeição. Mas, por enquanto, os
pensamentos para nós eles são densos,
eles são reais. As aparências que eles
se referem são coisas verdadeiras.
E eu analiso a partir do karma, a partir
da causalidade, eu tenho uma análise
complexa disso que é útil por um tempo e
depois vai ser abandonada também, né?
Mas por enquanto nós estamos seguindo
com essa estética. Então, por exemplo,
quem tiver num retiro pode estar nessa
etapa
de desenvolver chamata. Então, o
desenvolvimento de chamata é considerado
alguma coisa super necessária.
Super necessário. Se nós não
desenvolvermos chamata, nós simplesmente
proliferamos pensamentos. E eu não não
tenho não posso ter nenhuma esperança de
encontrar alguma coisa simplesmente
seguindo pensamentos. Isso não vai
produzir nada que não sejam outros
pensamentos que também se dissolvem.
Então nós, isso vai produzindo um
esgotamento.
Esse esgotamento
talvez
em algum momento com vá convergir para
nós buscarmos um caminho espiritual.
Porque se nós estamos simplesmente no
sansara,
gerando imagens, perseguindo imagens,
abandonando aquilo inevitavelmente,
seguindo outras imagens e abandonando e
seguindo outras e abandonando, é natural
que a gente tome isso por base e
pergunte: "Afinal, é só isso?
Eu tô me aproximando da morte e é só
isso que eu vou fazer? Não tem mais
nada.
Então, a própria dispersão mental dentro
do sansara, ela vai produzindo uma base
para nós buscarmos
compreender de uma forma mais profunda.
Se nós pensamos,
se nos vem esse tipo de questão, então é
natural que a gente tente resolver isso
e eventualmente nós estamos tão ocupados
que a gente não consegue
pensar senão muito eventualmente, uma
vez por ano.
A pessoa num dia especial ela pensa, mas
será que a vida é isso?
E logo em seguida acontece alguma coisa,
ela sai correndo porque ela tem que
fazer muitas coisas,
mas pode surgir esse
esse despertar
e a pessoa pensa, não, a vida deve ser
algo extraordinário,
tem uma complexidade enorme
e eu tô simplesmente fazendo tarefas. Eu
não consigo ver, entender esse mistério
gigante da minha própria vida, que eu
não sei de onde eu surjo, por que eu tô
vivo, como que segue a minha vida dia
após dia e como que ela vai terminar.
Tudo isso é misterioso.
E as próprias mães não sabem como que os
filhos surgem, como que a vida surge.
E elas também não sabem sobre o que que
vai acontecer com elas, de onde elas
vieram, para onde elas vão.
Os velhos também não sabem, as crianças
também não sabem.
Então, nós estamos dentro de um mundo
muito estranho
que a vida segue, mas nós não temos uma
compreensão.
Então, pode ser que a gente desperte em
algum momento para isso, né?
Então, esse é o momento em que nós vamos
começar o caminho.
Então, esse caminho ele pode se
apresentar de várias formas.
pode se apresentar através
da visão da compaixão,
aonde nós olhamos os seres e vemos que
eles estão perdidos.
Eles estão mais perdidos do que nós. Por
quê? Porque nós já entendemos a
impermanência e eles ainda não
entenderam.
Eles têm uma visão rígida da realidade.
Então eles estão fixados a que as coisas
ocorram de um certo jeito. Eles não
entendem como que as coisas surgem e
depois tudo muda, tudo cessa. E eles
então tão muito vulneráveis a todo tipo
de sofrimento.
Então nós olhamos isso e aí nós entramos
no caminho. A entrada no caminho, ela
poderia ser aqui, a gente sempre sugere
isso, né? As pessoas se aproximam, a
gente diz: "Prque chama".
Então, a gente vai praticando chamata.
Mas a chamata inicial ela é
ela é apenas eh para nos acalmar. Nós
não estamos praticando verdadeiramente
chama, mas nós acalmamos a mente. Então
a gente acalma e estuda. A gente vai
estudar o que o Buda falou.
Num certo momento, nós vamos praticar
moralidade.
Por quê? Porque nós, olhando os outros
seres nos seus sofrimentos,
brota em nós a aspiração de que eles se
livrem do sofrimento,
né? Nós vemos que
nós já desenvolvemos algum nível de
habilidade
e nós entendemos um pouco melhor as
coisas e assim olhando para eles, a
gente vê que eles estão sofrendo coisas
inúteis que a gente poderia ajudá-los a
escapar, mas eles também não ouvem e não
se liberam.
Então, nós vamos praticar eh aqui na
nossa estrutura,
a gente fala de metabávana.
Por quê? Porque metabávana
eh
sintetiza toda essa prática que vai
culminar em bodita, no voto de bodsatua.
Então, nós olhamos pros seres, a gente
aspira que eles se libertem do
sofrimento,
encontrem
a felicidade
e se liberem das causas verdadeiras do
sofrimento e encontra as verdadeiras
causas da felicidade. Ainda que a gente
não entenda bem quais são as verdadeiras
causas do sofrimento, o que que é o
verdadeiro sofrimento,
quais são as verdadeiras causas da
felicidade, o que seria a verdadeira
causa da felicidade. Ainda assim, nós
temos um barco com aquelas palavras.
Aquelas palavras vão sendo
ressignificadas
com o tempo e nós conseguimos andar de
uma forma melhor, né? Então, metabana eu
considero assim de grande importância, é
uma meditação que o próprio Buda
ensinou né?
Então, eh, eu vejo isso como uma grande
importância, mesmo se se vocês têm, por
exemplo, algum tipo de doença, mesmo que
a gente não entenda essa conexão, quando
nós praticamos metabávana,
nós aliviamos os obstáculos que possam
surgir a partir de doenças
e eventualmente nós também curamos
doenças em nós e nos outros.
simplesmente por metaba, né? Isso
descrito assim, a gente vai pensar, bom,
agora o lama,
né assim
ficou odara, né,
eh, eh, enfim, a era de aquários é isso,
né? É assim, mas o que acontece é assim,
que a gente não vê bem, é que os
pensamentos que a gente tem, todos eles
têm uma conexão com as energias.
Então vocês vejam, tá todo mundo
sentadinho aqui, vocês olharem como é
que tá a energia de vocês, cada um tá
com uma energia de um jeito,
né? É assim, nós temos essas energias
que vocês decidem como é que é, vocês
não decidem, elas vêm carmicamente.
Então, vamos supor que e aqui nós somos
todos amigos, né? Eu acho assim, né? Aí
todo mundo amigo, então nós estamos nos
sentindo bem aqui dentro.
né? A nossa energia ela flui bem, mas se
vocês tivessem num ambiente tenso, onde
as pessoas reclamam umas das outras,
aqui nunca ninguém reclama de ninguém,
entende? É assim, e nem do tempo e nem
de nada.
Então, por exemplo, vocês experimentem
uma sensação boa, a energia toda
fluindo,
aí de repente vocês se lembram de alguém
que enfim
vocês têm alguma dificuldade,
casualmente tá chegando pro retiro e vai
ficar na cama de cima de vocês ou na de
baixo assim, né? Aí, pronto. Aí aquilo,
aí vocês olhem a energia. Então, vocês
vem como que a gente podia pensar, tal
pessoa tem uma energia pesada e causa um
problema sobre mim mesmo.
Mas aí, como vocês são praticantes,
vocês podem dizer: "Como tal pessoa
aciona um nível cármico em mim que me
adoece,
mas é o meu karma que tá me adoecendo".
né? Assim, ou vocês podem dizer, tal
pessoa se manifesta de modo natural,
mas eu,
por um obstáculo interno,
espantosamente faço surgir uma energia
dentro de mim
que acontece nesse caso, mas acontece em
outro e acontece em outro também. É a
mesma coisa. E se eu não cuidar,
eu encontrei um fator de adoecimento
recorrente
que vai
terminar produzindo uma configuração
interna no corpo. E a configuração
interna no corpo é um sintoma. Agora,
vamos supor, se eu olhar para essa
pessoa e para todos os outros que eu
eventualmente eu me sinto meio torto
e disser que ele encontra felicidade,
que ele encontra as causas da
felicidade, supere o sofrimento e as
causas do sofrimento.
Aí quando nós olhamos para aquela
pessoa, a nossa energia é diferente. Por
quê? Porque nós não estamos operando com
energia cármica de rejeição, etc. nossa
energia diferente. Aí pode ser que nós
simplesmente tenhamos retirado a causa
sutil de uma série de sintomas que
poderiam acontecer, entende? É assim, é
isso.
Então, metab é curativo.
O Tocudaçã, que era um mestre de cura,
ele dizia: "Você tiver uma doença,
comece pacificando a relação com todos
os as pessoas ao redor e eu incluiria as
pessoas que aparecem em sonhos também".
Vocês tiverem pessoas falecidas
aparecendo,
vocês olhem. Se a pessoa aparece eh
falecida aparece, o que que acontece com
a energia de vocês?
Energia se entorta. Então, a pessoa
falecida tá
produzindo uma alteração
específica na energia de vocês.
Se a pessoa falecida é uma construção
mental ou não é,
ela é uma construção mental 100%. Por
quê? Porque se ela fosse uma presença em
carne e ossos, vocês olhariam para ela,
teriam essa perturbação.
Mas a gente poderia dizer, essa
perturbação, ela vem de um nível
cármico. Eu não preciso dessa
perturbação. Agora, se a pessoa aparece
como um sonho, como uma visão,
é a mesma coisa. Se a perturbação
acontece, ela acontece por um nível
cármico. Então, eu posso simplesmente
rezar pelos seres vivos e pelos mortos a
partir de metabávana e liberar esses
sofrimentos. É assim. Então eu acho
melhor fazer isso.
Ah, esse aspecto também a gente pode a
gente pode colocar, olhar tudo isso
dentro do lado de cá do rio do
sofrimento, onde nós damos densidade
para tudo isso, mas a gente pode olhar
do outro lado, que é melhor,
eh, reconhecendo a não dualidade,
luminosidade, vacuidade de todas essas
experiências, né? Aí os seres que nos
perturbam, eles se transformam
numa numa compreensão mais profunda. Por
quê?
Por exemplo, nós podemos usar essa
chave.
Não sei se vocês já perceberam que
vários seres já passaram pela vida de
vocês em várias circunstâncias, mas
eventualmente os seres passam e nós
ficamos presos por uma por uma emoção ou
por um pensamento. E cada vez que a
gente acessa aquele ser, aquelas
emoções, aqueles pensamentos eles
voltam, né? que é o que acontece quando
a gente sonha com mãe que faleceu, com o
pai que com avô, alguma coisa assim, e
aquilo produz um efeito em nós, né?
Então, mesmo que esses efeitos
aconteçam,
né, vocês não neguem isso, mas vocês
perguntem: "Quando isso acontece,
essa pessoa que eu tô lembrando, meu
avô, minha mãe, meu pai, etc., que idade
eles teriam nessa época?
Por que que a gente pergunta isso? Por
quê? Porque nós mesmos, em cada idade,
nós nos manifestamos de um jeito.
Então, eu me dou conta que eu não tô me
relacionando com aquela pessoa. Então,
tô me relacionando com aquela pessoa
naquele tempo que ela se manifestou de
um certo jeito. Mas ela também já é uma
outra coisa. Ela foi uma outra coisa.
Então, é mais fácil eu olhando assim eu
me liberar daquilo. Por quê? Porque
quando nós dizemos, "Eu sonhei com a
minha mãe", parece que é uma entidade
única, mas ela não é. Ela é um ser que
foi um bebê, que foi uma criança
pequena, foi várias coisas e foi aquilo
que eu me prendi quando eu falo a minha
mãe,
né? É assim, ela não é aquilo, mas eu me
prendi com uma aparência, então é mais
fácil eu ver que eu me prendi com
aparência. E assim, eu vendo que eu me
prendi com aparência, eu posso dizer que
esse ser seja feliz, que esse tipo de
mente que opera desse modo se libere e
que isso se torne um caminho de
liberação para muitos seres quando isso
for completamente lucidado e resolvido.
E assim a gente aspira e nós vamos
curando as várias conexões. Essa cura
das várias conexões é a prática da
moralidade.
Se nós não tivermos essa cura, nós temos
vários ganchos que vão aparecer dentro
da meditação e vão nos puxar.
Então nós estamos nós estamos praticando
chamata e aparece
a mãe, avó, o pai, né, dizendo: "Você tá
fazendo uma coisa inútil aí, acorde,
você precisa ganhar dinheiro. Você
sempre foi um fracassado e nós Ah, tem
razão." Sim, é isso. Au, ainda bem que
ele apareceu. Agora eu acordei, eu sei
que que eu tenho que fazer.
É assim.
Então esse é o ponto. Então nós temos
várias dessas conexões. Então nós
precisamos metabava, né? Esses seres
aparecem que eles sejam felizes, que
eles superem o sofrimento contra as
causas da felicidade, superem as causas
do sofrimento. Eventualmente, pessoal,
vocês podem começar a ver os deuses
locais, que eu não vou descrever. Aí
vocês vejam os deuses locais e aí vocês
que eles sejam felizes. Todos eles
pertencem ao sansar.
Sejam felizes, superem o sofrimento,
encontrem as causas da felicidade,
supere as causas do sofrimento, sempre
reconhecendo a não dualidade. Os deuses
locais, eles não existem em si mesmo,
eles existem não doais conosco, né?
Por exemplo, o vento do Bacupari é uma
deidade existente aqui, né? Se vocês
tiverem uma versão ao vento do Bacupari,
vocês não tão conseguindo fazer a coisa
direito. Ele vai perturbar a energia de
vocês. Então, na linguagem tibetana, a
gente deveria fazer uma torma todo dia e
oferecer pro vento do Macupari.
Ou seja, ô vento do bacubari, aí você se
liberta de toda a aflição que vocês têm
dentro.
Esse é um processo chamânico que o
budismo terminou, especialmente os
tibetanos terminaram,
não só os tibetanos, porque isso começa,
na verdade, na Índia, né, quando o
budismo começa a dialogar com a tradição
védica das oferendas, né?
Aí ele vai resolvendo isso.
Mas a nossa oferenda é sempre uma
oferenda de sabedoria aqui, que é a mais
rápida, né? A gente olha e vre, eu agora
eu me incomodo com isso, me incomodo com
aquilo, agora eu libero isso.
Se a gente não praticar essa moralidade,
nós temos ganchos,
laços que vão nos puxar na hora a gente
tá atingindo a iluminação. Aí vem um
vento e nós ah não, assim não. Eu quero
um dia calmo para atingir iluminação. Aí
nós, não, não, isso não é possível.
Aí nós temos regiões fixas que são que
se tornam obstrutores do Dharma. Então
demônios interferências
fantasmagóricas,
espíritos
[Música]
invejosos, obstrutores do dharma. Nós
vamos obstrutores. Por quê? Porque nós,
a visão se estabelece, mas não naquele
caso. Aquele caso ali aquilo é real,
externo dual independente.
Eu não tenho nada a fazer porque aquilo
é um obstáculo mesmo.
Então, a moralidade é essa região onde
nós precisamos trabalhar isso. Quem
tiver em retiro, pessoal,
quem tiver em retiro vai precisar
praticar moralidade, porque o sansar ele
é todo torto. É sempre torto. Não há
lugar que não haja sofrimento. Nós temos
sofrimento nos vários lugares. É assim.
Aí vocês vão pro Canadá, tem sofrimento
em Canadá. vão para para Paris, tem
sofrimento, eles caminham e choram na
beira do céan, né? Aí vocês estão em
Recife,
aí vocês choram na beira dos rios de
Recife, assim, aquilo é um lugar
maravilhoso para chorar,
né? Então aqui vocês caminham pelo
parcão do lado do Guaíba e choram assim,
sempre tem um bom lugar para chorar, né?
É assim. Por quê? Porque não há lugar
que não tenha frustração. Uma vez que a
gente carrega tudo isso dentro. Segundo
o Buda, que é fácil de ver. Cada coisa
que a gente se conecta tem uma
expectativa. Tendo uma expectativa
é é fatal, vai dar problema. Então nós
estamos em retiro, nós vamos ter
problemas, mas a gente vai transformar
os os problemas em prática. Esse é o
ponto. Então aqui nós temos mais jeito.
Então vocês olhem esses problemas como
obstrutores do dharma. Quando nós
estamos em retiro e aparecem os
obstrutores,
a gente agradece.
Pá, você chegou na hora certa do
instrutor. Se tiver mais uns aí, por
favor, venham todos tudo aqui. Fica aqui
tudo junto com com o
com os praticantes mais experientes que
então eles resolvem isso, né?
Aí, por favor, tudo em volta da casinha
do Vini. E aí?
E o Vini vai pum produzindo liberação.
Tinha acontecido, ó, viu?
É assim, quanto mais obstrutores,
melhor.
E que eles sejam rápidos assim.
Por quê? Porque é assim, aquilo é o que
eu preciso trabalhar. Eu vou deixar pra
próxima vida dos obstrutores, pessoal.
Ah, vem tudo, né? É assim, tudo ali
paraa casinha do Viné, não sou eu que tô
chamando.
Vini, se acontecer alguma coisa, fui eu,
viu? Desculpa qualquer coisa
assim. Mas então,
então esse é o ponto. A gente precisa
ver quando nós estamos na na parte de
moralidade, né, a base da moralidade, a
gente precisa ver os obstrutores,
entender os obstrutores, das nossas
emoções, essas questões todas, mas isso
não são só as situações, como eu vou
dizer assim, situações negativas, né? As
situações negativas é fácil de ver.
levantou uma telha olha o problema, vai
cair água, vai dar aí tu vê na hora. Mas
se aparece um ser faiscante
assim, luzes douradas, o ser nem toca no
chão, uma aura de felicidade ao redor,
aí vocês corram, fechem a porta, se
escondam travesseiro por cima e aquilo
sim, aquilo é o problema.
Aí o senhor com certeza vai bater na
porta, viu V?
com a voz que vem do cé assim.
Não, não. Eh, como que é?
Arpas. Isso. E tu tá entendendo bem o
que eu tô dizendo? É assim. Aí, tu já
quer seu chazinho, avisa os amigos de
olha, deu para mim.
Qual é a situação? Nós somos mais
frágeis para para infelicidade ou paraa
felicidade?
Se a se a infelicidade chega com uma
cara de desgraça, o que que vocês fazem?
Fecham a porta e ficam lá. Se a se a
infelicidade chega com uma cara de céu
aberto e felicidade, o que que a gente
faz? A gente diz: "Bem-vinda,
assim, esse é o ponto. Isso é como nós
estamos dentro de uma roda, a gente de
modo geral entra na roda pelo lugar que
tá mais favorável.
É isso.
Isso é uma confissão, Ven. É uma
confissão.
Vocês viram os praticantes que a gente
tem aqui? Como é isso?
Tudo bem. Então é isso. Então vocês
estão entendendo que essa coisa de
moralidade faz sentido, né? Então
aparece os seres assim, você
encontre a felicidade,
né? contra as causas da felicidade,
supere o sofrimento, supere as as causas
do sofrimento. Então, sem atração, sem
aversão. Aí nós entendemos, se a gente
não tiver essa compreensão, a gente não
consegue praticar moralidade. Aí quando
vocês olham moralidade, aquilo já é algo
super profundo.
Metab na moralidade é super profundo.
Ele começa a se fundir com a própria
prática última.
E aí nós sentamos
chamata.
Só que chamata tem um obstáculo,
pessoal. Se chamata dá certo, não dá
certo.
Esse é o meu problema.
Por quê? Porque chama tem uma prática
dual.
Eh, eh, se eu tô com pensamentos, eu tô
seguindo alguma coisa, eu tô com mesmo
pensamentos de sabedoria, eles são uma
quebra de chamata.
E chamata é uma conexão com o reino dos
deuses da forma.
O reino dos deuses da forma é muito
melhor que o reino dos deuses do desejo.
Então, houve uma um processo
progressivo de densificação.
Esse processo ele tá descrito.
Dudimpoche vai descrever como também
tartam. Os mestres eles descrevem o
surgimento da vida. até o ponto onde nós
estamos.
Então, é como se tivesse níveis muito
sutis, que são movimentos sutis da mente
que tem uma longa duração, assim, uma
duração atemporal. Depois eles vão
densificando densificando
e surge os reinos da forma, que são
estados mentais particulares, mas eles
não tão ambientados.
em olhos ouvidos na lei língua e tato.
Mas tem um momento em que parece que
tudo melhora se eu tiver algo para
olhos, ouvidos, nariz, língua e tato que
ajuda a sustentar o estado mental
correspondente. Então, nesse momento, eu
me vinculo às experiências duais. Eu
crio algo dual. Eu vejo que se algo do
al tá presente na minha mente
e aquilo surge de olhos, ouvidos, níngua
e tato,
como uma ancoragem,
então aquele estado mental
correspondente ele
ele se estabiliza.
Aí quando a gente olha a foto de um
filho, por exemplo, eu posso lembrar um
filho, mas se eu olhar uma foto, ah,
então aquilo, aquelas luzes produzem
pelo efeito da consciência visual
que estimula uma posição da sexta
consciência,
eu tenho um elemento que
ancora a estabilidade de um estado
mental. Então, quando nós começamos a a
ancorar os estados mentais a partir de
olhos, ouvidos, nariz, língua e tato,
nesse momento nós entramos no mundo do
desejo.
Dali paraa frente nós estamos sempre
buscando alguma coisa para ter um estado
mental
que a gente aspira assim, assim. Então,
nós estamos sempre na dependência de
aparências. Nós estamos sempre buscando
aparências.
Aí nós criamos a sensação de que pode
haver um mundo especial,
que é um mundo aonde as aparências vão
ser favoráveis para nós. E a gente
descobre rapidamente que esse mundo
especial,
ele é um mundo
que funciona para alguns seres, mas não
para outros.
assim,
e esses mundos especiais, eles são
surgidos e eles cessam.
Então nós vamos progressivamente nos
colocando na posição de entender as
quatro nobres verdades.
Aí quando nós avançamos nas quatro noves
verdades, então a gente vai compreender
que
há um sofrimento geral, que é o
sofrimento da ignorância.
disso brota um sofrimento enquanto
os aspectos grosseiros,
ou seja, os objetos que eu quero na
minha frente, eles não aparecem,
aparecem outros que conectam com estados
mentais aflitivos.
Aí eu quero que aquilo mude.
Os objetos que produzem estados
eh favoráveis para mim, eles são
impermanentes. Eventualmente eu perco
eles. E aí nós temos uma
inevitável
ah necessidade de nos mantermos em ação
e buscarmos sempre alguma coisa que a
gente nunca encontra. não termina
e assim surgem os três animais.
Aí o Buda vai descrever as quatro noves
verdades, vai descrever bodetita quando
nós percebemos a artificialidade de tudo
isso e a gente entende que existe uma
mente livre que não precisa se engajar
nisso. Aí nesse momento, então surge
Bodetita, a nossa aspiração de
beneficiar os outros seres e a nós
mesmos. E dali surge o caminho que tá
descrito em oito passos.
É assim. Aí nós estamos sempre
comentando esses itens. Os quatro nobres
verdades, nobre caminho de oito passos.
sendo que se nós não tivermos uma
prática anterior de moralidade, a gente
nem escuta sobre isso, porque a gente
não tem conexão.
Quando a gente oferece, a gente faz a
prática de da mandala, oferecimento de
mandala,
nós estamos justamente lembrando isso,
né?
Então, nós estamos num ponto que a gente
a gente relembra essa terra pura.
Então, a gente vai
lembrar nesse oferecimento de mandala, a
gente
encontra um sansara mais favorável.
A gente vai lembrar os aspectos
agradáveis do ambiente.
Hum. vai lembrar o Monte Sumero, ou
seja, Monte Meru, os quatro continentes,
o sol e a lua. Então, a gente vai
lembrar da roda da vida, como o Buda
descreve a roda da vida. E é dentro do
contexto da roda da vida, da do giro da
roda da vida,
que nós vamos, enfim, entender que é
possível seguir a prática.
E o que que a prática faz?
Se a gente não tiver essa compreensão, a
gente não entende os múltiplos reinos. A
gente não entende o fato de que nós
estamos sempre transmigrando entre
estados mentais. A gente não entende
isso. Aí os ensinamentos não funcionam
direito. Assim, a oferenda de a oferenda
de mandala, ela é essa compreensão. Se
nós estamos nesse lugar, os ensinamentos
do Buda funcionam.
Aí funciona as práticas de moralidade,
as quatro nobres verdades são entendidas
e o caminho então se descortina.
[Música]
Então aí surge ah essa visão, né? Eu vou
praticando dentro do ensinamento da
iluminação de sabedoria primordial, eu
vou praticando chamata. E a própria
prática de chamata, ela vai amadurecer
na
experiência da mente livre de
características.
Se isso acontecer,
então nós podemos seguir adiante no
caminho. Então essa mente livre de
características é a base que vai
eh
que vai permitir a prática do satipatana
do anapanassat.
Eu preciso olhar as coisas desde um
lugar
amplo e livre.
Então, a mente livre de características,
ela vai dar origem, num certo momento,
a grande abertura. Mas a grande
abertura, ela abarca a mente livre de
características e a mente com
características.
Mas a mente livre de características não
abarca a mente com característica.
Então, ela não é a grande abertura, ela
é uma abertura
parcial.
Mas essa abertura parcial nos permite
andar. Então essa compreensão eu acho
ela super importante, assim, super
importante, porque nós temos uma
tendência, a gente poderia listar uma
série de obstáculos à visão. Um dos
obstáculos da visão é nós nos fixarmos
na estética da
moralidade
e na estética de chamata, que é muito
recorrente. Nós fazemos isso.
Então essa estética, ela surge assim:
"Uau, eu tive maus pensamentos, eu fiz
coisas inadequadas,
né? Eu não consigo manter uma mente com
uma moralidade perfeita. Não consigo
manter isso. Então isso de um lado. De
outro lado é assim, por mais que eu
pratique chamata, sempre vem pensamentos
de onde é que brota essa usina de
loucura interna.
Eu já vejo que tem pensamentos que nem
são meus. Eu não tenho conexão com
aquilo, n? Essa é uma experiência
interessante. Vai aprofundando chamada
termina descobrindo que começa a
aparecer coisas que você não, não. Isso
nessa vida eu não vivi isso. E na vida
anterior eu também não vivi isso. Não
sei de onde é que tá brotando esse tipo
de loucura.
Eu não tenho conexão com isso. Mas como
é que isso brota na minha mente? Que que
é isso?
Hum.
Na verdade, a nossa mente, ela começa a
ganhar uma certa onisciência
e nós começamos a andar por outros
mundos.
Por quê? Porque aquilo que a gente chama
de nossa mente não é a nossa mente, é
uma mente como uma onda.
Mas essa mente como uma onda, ela é o
próprio mar. Aí quando essa mente começa
a se ampliar, ela vê outras ondas.
Então, a onda tá indo assim, mas ela vê
outras ondas
e ela reconhece que aquelas outras ondas
nunca deram origem a essa que tá aqui.
Aquilo é uma outra coisa. é uma pessoa
estranha que ela tenha isso. Se a pessoa
ficar presa as múltiplas visões que vão
aparecendo,
né, mesmo com essa questão aparentemente
profunda de identificar o karma de onde
veio,
a pessoa tá armadilhada dentro dos
obstáculos.
H, então, na verdade, nós estamos
olhando todas essas experiências e nós
estamos vendo eh que elas surgem e elas
cessam, elas não têm importância em si
mesmo.
Quando nós estamos trabalhando em nível
de moralidade, nós operamos de um jeito,
mas aqui nós já estamos operando de um
outro modo. Mas aí as loucuras aparecem,
os conteúdos aparecem e nós voltamos na
prática de chamata pro espaço livre. Mas
a gente percebe que essa é uma função
praticamente infinita, porque outros
pensamentos virão e se e desaparecerão,
eles virão e desaparecerão e nós vamos
seguindo com esse sofrimento, né?
Esse é o tempo então de surgir as
instruções de vipassana.
Se não vierem as instruções de
vipassana,
nós vamos perdendo a energia
e nós retornamos ao sansara. Então nós
seguimos presos na roda, né? Então, como
o Buda descreve,
ah, a gente só vai ficar salvo de ser de
passar por uma repescagem
quando nós atingirmos oitavo boom,
sendo que entrar no primeiro boom já é
muito difícil.
Então, esse esse é o ponto. Então, é só
lá pelo oitavo boom que a gente vai
escapar disso, né?
sendo que o sexto boom é prágna.
Prana é a compreensão
ã do prágina paramita e a visão prágina
da realidade.
Então eu posso ter a visão prágina da
realidade, reconhecer vacuidade das
aparências e ainda assim eu posso
eu posso ser repescado pelo Sansara. Eu
posso desenvolver uma habilidade da
vacuidade
que opera
sempre que eu precisar.
aparece alguma coisa, eu olho, não, esse
poste aqui, o vazio dele, a delusão
correspondente,
qualquer lugar que tu olhar, tu pode
fazer um discurso sobre aquilo.
Ainda assim, nós podemos ser engolidos.
Então, o próprio D John Limpo, ele vai
descrever isso, né? Ele faz um discurso
sobre a realidade, aí tem um animal que
ruge, aí ele tem medo,
aí ele não entende como é que ele pode
ter medo se o animal rugiu e ele falou:
"Dá para cuidar de tudo antes".
É assim. Aí aquilo fica meio assim.
Então isso corresponde a sexta e sétimo,
sexto e sétimo boome. No oitavo boom,
ele não vai tremer com o rugido do
animal.
Aí no nono bume, ele é o Buda andando no
mundo. No oitavo, ele é um Buda parado.
No nono, ele é um Buda que anda em meio
às múltiplas circunstâncias.
Assim,
ele é um nirmanacai andando em meio ao
mundo né?
Então, o que vai nos levar até o final
do caminho é de pássana. Aí nós vamos
trabalhando um tanto nós silenciamos, um
tanto nós praticamos viásana com as
aparências que forem surgindo. Aí nós
vamos andando
assim.
Então aqui no retiro, o que que nós
vamos fazer? Em princípio, a gente não
vai mais olhar nenhuma parte dos
ensinamentos da iluminação, sabedoria
primordial
e nem do prágio da paramita. Nós vamos
olhar nada. Nós vamos tomar isso por
base e nós vamos seguindo
os textos que vão propondo temas para
nós contemplarmos.
É assim,
termos para nós usarmos aquela visão que
que abriu, que você desenvolveu. Então
eu acho que a missão aqui do a canista
aqui onde nós estamos é isso,
é nós operarmos meditação.
A visão é como se a gente já tivesse
ouvido. Então a gente vem para praticar
meditação ação fruição.
E e a parte de visão, eu espero poder
trabalhar a partir de perguntas e
respostas. Então, se vocês vão me
trazendo temas, eu vou trabalhando esses
temas,
mas eu mesmo não vou parar o processo
pra gente retornar paraa visão. Não vou,
mas dentro da pergunta e resposta aí eu
vou trabalhando. Por quê? Porque a nossa
prática é a prática de visão. E aí na
medida em que nós vamos andando, surgem
obstáculos. A minha função é ajudar a
superar aqueles obstáculos.
Então eu espero que a gente no meio de
tudo isso, a gente possa ir conversando,
falando e trabalhando esses temas.
Então é isso aí. Então eu vou começar.
Hum. Vai cair a bateria.
Nós estamos sem luz.
ficou sem som.
O mapa Maca comprou aquilo placa muito
boa.
É assim, China promovendo dharma.
Então
assim, eu ouvi. Então nós vamos começar
com o com o Ana Panassat. Eu acho super
importante isso, pessoal.
Porque nós vamos agora, o Buda vai
descrever os praticantes.
Então essa descrição do Buda, a gente
nós temos várias descrições dos
praticantes, né? A gente tem os
Vidiadaras e tem vários tipos de
praticantes. E nós temos também as
pessoas com tomam iniciações.
Aí os praticantes vão fazer as práticas
disso, daquilo. Aí nós temos ainda os
bodsatvas, os boomes todos. Então, tem
vários tipos de praticantes. Eu acho que
a melhor descrição é a descrição que vem
aqui, que são oito tipos de praticante.
Elas são muito simples, muito diretas e
nos ajudam a reconhecer o que que os
outros estão fazendo, até mesmo pelo
pelo que os outros fazem. Aí
imediatamente a gente vê. Então, nós
mesmos podemos ver em que ponto nós
estamos facilmente.
O critério do Buda é essencialmente
ah
o critério da originação dependente.
Aí dentro do critério da originação
dependente, se tá operando com
originação dependente, cai numa
categoria,
e não tá na oitava categoria, tá em
qualquer uma das anteriores.
As outras categorias tu vai olhando de
acordo com o tipo de gancho que tu tá tá
ligado para produzir as ações de
originação dependente. É sempre assim.
Aí tu tá 100% daquilo. Tu tá antes de qu
das 8. Se tu tiver alguma aspiração e
entrar na corrente e te livrar de
coisas, a tu tá na primeira.
Se tomou refúgio no Buda, dar na sanga
do jeito que foi, aí já tá na segunda.
A segunda é super importante porque ela
é, ela também é muito difícil, porque
você já vem assim, eu tenho que tomar
refúgio no Buda, dar-me na sanga. Muito
difícil. A pessoa não tem refúgio no
Buda. A pessoa tem refúgio e alguma
secção de sansara,
sendo que o Buda, por enquanto, ele é
ele é um é um quadro na parede. De vez
em quando eu acesso, entro naquilo, mas
eu sigo a minha vida, porque a minha
vida é a minha vida e a minha vida tem
que seguir.
Aí quando a gente tem isso, nós estamos
com refúgio
na bolha que nós estamos operando.
Então, nós estamos antes do primeiro,
nós estamos antes do segundo. A gente
não entrou na corrente.
A entrada na corrente não é fácil.
Aí nós entramos na corrente e aí tem
assim, eu entrei na corrente, mas eu
tenho um conteúdo cármico atuante. Esse
conteúdo cármico vai me conduzir a
renascimentos
por um tempo.
O Buda vai sete vidas, pelo menos.
entrou na corrente de sete vidas. Esse
ponto eu acho bem interessante porque
ele conecta com a noção das iniciações
vajaiana, né? Aí tu toma uma iniciação,
aí tu iniciação de uma deidade, aí em
sete vidas deve atingir a liberação.
Então essa iniciação ela é tomada quando
toma refúgio. Então toma iniciação,
refúgio, sete vidas. Então aquilo
dialoga bem com essa estrutura.
E aí tu tem aqueles que não que não
voltam, aqueles que voltam uma vez e tem
os que não voltam e tem os arrados de
acordo com as estruturas de karma. Então
o Buda vai descrever também o reino da
forma e da não forma no meio disso, né?
E eu vou descrever aqui também, né?
Então isso é bem importante porque a
gente vê facilmente onde é que nós
estamos.
De modo geral, nós estamos nas oito
consciências.
Nós temos uma descrição de mundo que não
é jambo de vipa.
Descrição de mundo nossa é assim, eu tô
morando nessa cidade e aqui eu preciso
disso, preciso daquilo, faço isso, faço
aquilo. E essa é a visão.
A gente não consegue converter o local
que a gente tá vivendo na experiência
dos seis reinos do Monte Meru, no
centro, no topo que a gente aspira, que
ao reino dos deuses. A gente não
consegue ver isso. A gente não consegue
ver tudo regido por yama. A gente não
consegue ver que acima de Yama nós temos
ah nós temos mara. A gente não consegue
ver como que o reino da forma deu origem
ao reino do desejo e como aquilo foi o
apocalipse do reino da forma.
Ele degrada.
E aí todos os deuses da forma diziam:
"Que horror!" Aí nós
aparecemos com corpos dentro do mundo do
desejo.
Aí dentro disso nós vamos seguindo, né?
A gente não percebe nada disso, não
percebe que no momento que a gente
afunda
e surge dentro de um corpo buscando
eh buscando experiências a partir de
olhos, ouvidos, nariz, língua e tato.
Sem perceber que não importa as
experiências de olhos, ouvidos, nariz,
língua e tato. O sofrimento não se
libera com isso. Eu posso colocar todas
as aparências favoráveis de olhos,
ouvidos, nariz, língua e tato. E ainda
assim as quatro montanhas vem e blum
blum, ou seja, envelhecimento, doença,
decrepitude e morte vem e sacode aquilo.
Eu eu não consigo perceber que o mundo
o mundo dos deuses do desejo não resiste
a as quatro montanhas.
que eu tô
magnetizado pelo mundo dos deuses e isso
significa que eu tô sobre o poder de
mara.
Então, no momento que eu fico sobre o
poder daquele que satisfaz os meus
desejos, que amara, eu tô no mundo do
desejo. Então, nós
operando, acho que chegou alguém aqui,
operando no mundo do desejo,
nós estamos
presos a Mara. Então, a gente entende
como que Mara é o principal deus do
mundo dos desejos. Ele tá no topo. Por
quê? Porque ele define a forma de operar
que vai ficar na dependência de olhos,
ouvidos, nariz, língua e tato. Eu tô
operando desse jeito aí, tá? Eu tô nesse
mundo.
Mas isso é uma mente livre. Aí existe
uma degradação
das mentes que operam com as quatro
qualidades incomensuráveis e estão fora
da dependência de olhos, ouvidos, nariz,
língua e tato.
Aí surge mara.
Aí dentro da experiência de Mara surgem
os deuses de felicidade,
porque são as experiências aonde nós
temos
conexão, a gente vai chamar aquilo de
felicidade.
Aí vem as mútias no oposto. Os deuses de
felicidade estão lá no topo do Monte
Meru abaixo
dentro da terra, no fundo, equivalente
ao Monte Meru, tá a desgraça. Ou seja,
em vez de eu me relacionar com coisas
que eu acho favoráveis, eu só encontro o
problema.
Então tem uma descrição complexa do
reino do reino delusivo
dos infernos. São reinos delusivos,
pessoal. São construções mentais
assim.
Mas como nós surgimos na dependência,
nós surgimos na dependência
eh de olhos, ouvidos, nariz, língua e
tato, aspirando ser feliz com as
aparências de olhos, ouvidos, olhos,
ouvidos, língua e tato, olhos, ouvidos,
nariz, língua e tato. Então eu tô com
esse obstáculo assim, né?
Aí nós, a gente não contemplou isso
direito, mas a gente precisa contemplar
esse aspecto e com isso a gente termina
entendendo a roda da vida. Entende
aquilo assim? Roda da vida é um
ensinamento super importante,
né?
Então, nós vamos reconhecer a roda da
vida como uma manifestação
luminosa da nossa mente. Nós vamos
entender a roda da vida como uma
manifestação vazia e luminosa.
Mas nesse momento a gente não tem essa
experiência. Nós temos uma experiência
de cotidiano.
A gente não atravessou, não entrou e não
tomou refúgio de fato,
né assim né?
Mas aí o Buda vai dar ensinamentos.
Então nós estamos no Anapanassat.
Aí o Ananda vai dizer assim, eu ouvi.
Acho que eu tomo mais um chimarrão aqui.
Em certa ocasião, o abençoado estava em
Savate, no palácio da mãe de Migara,
no Parque do Oriente.
A gente não se dá bem conta, mas Migar
era uma mulher e ela ofereceu esse esse
lugar pro Buda, né? Eu acho isso muito
meritório, muito maravilhoso. A gente
tem que lembrar disso.
Ele tava junto com muitos discípulos
siors bem conhecidos.
como o venerável Chariputra,
o venerável Marra Mogalana, o venerável
Marra Caçapa, o venerável Marra Kacana,
o venerável Marra Cotita, venerável
Marraha Capina, venerável Marra Cunda, o
venerável Anuruda, o venerável Revata, o
venerável Ananda e outros discípulos
siors bem conhecidos.
Naquela ocasião, os bicos siors
ensinavam e instruíam os bicos júniores.
Então aqui, pessoal, vocês olhem assim:
bico poderia ser pensado como monge, mas
bico na verdade não é simplesmente um
monge. bico nessa sanga do Buda
são aqueles que estão operando desse
modo. Eles estão operando com lucidez.
Eles estão do outro lado olhando as
aparências
e então os bicos podem incluir também os
leigos.
Então, esses bicos, alguns ensinavam,
instruíam 20, 30, 40 bicos júniores. E
os bicos júiors, ensinados e instruídos
pelos bicos
atingiram sucessivos estágios de
distinção. Então, aqui vocês já vejam a
terra pura do Buda, porque o Buda ele
abre jambo de vipa, descreve essa
aparência. as pessoas se agregam ao
redor dele dentro de uma sociedade que
faz outras coisas completamente
diferentes, mas eles estão no meio de
uma
terra pura. O Buda, pelo poder dele, ele
cria uma terra pura onde aquele é o
ponto principal. Por isso que haviam
bicos júniores. Eles estavam vindo de
outros lugares e estavam sendo acolhidos
pela sanga.
naquela ocasião, no 15º dia do Posata,
na o Posata é o mês, na noite da lua
cheia da cerimônia de Paranavana, de
Pavarana, aliás, quando eles vão fazer
as confissões e os votos e
o abençoado estava sentado no ar, ao ar
livre, rodeado pela sangue de bicos.
Quando, observando cuidadosamente a
silenciosa sangue de bicicos, ele assim
falou: "Bicos,
estou contente com esse progresso. Minha
mente está satisfeita com esse
progresso.
Portanto, estimule ainda mais a energia
para atingir o que não foi atingido,
para alcançar o que não foi alcançado,
para realizar o que não foi realizado.
Eu esperarei aqui em Savate pela lua
cheia do quarto mês de Comode. Então é o
mês seguinte. Eu disse alguma coisa
errada assim, vocês estão indo embora.
Pessoal se levantou aqui. Pessoal, não
sei o que que houve. É, na verdade eles
estão indo pra cozinha agora. Fazer o
quê?
Quem?
Fernando
tá
disse para ele que é karma. Pode falar,
tá?
Volta de chimarrão.
Esse frio assim, né? Isso aí pode dar
alguma coisa assim.
que nunca teve cálculo renal ou ou
cólica renal não sabe o que que é, né?
Porque é horrível.
Bom, então é assim, pessoal, eu fiz essa
introdução
e eu vou parar nesse ponto. Por quê?
Porque eu vou agora abrir um um espaço
pra gente conversar.
Então eu aspiro que possam surgir
perguntas online ou
ou presenciais daquilo que a gente falou
até agora, que é uma introdução da
introdução, a gente não começou nada
ainda. E aí o Maca pode começar.
Não tem
assim porque paraa transmissão, né? Eu
posso conectar aqui um microfonezinho.
Aí ele fala ali, eu transmito por aqui.
Ou pode vir um outro, né?
Esse aqui.
Entendi.
Não, mas aí eu penso, como é que vai ser
a a consulta? Como é que ele vai falar
agora?
Se eu colocar aquele microfone que fica
uma lapela aqui e uma lapela na outra
pessoa, pode ser esse. Aí a gente
interrompe esse aqui. Aí eu desligo
esse, faço um clique aqui.
Sabia que eu ia usar meu microfone. Eu
não tenho apego nenhum.
Deixa eu ver. Acho que é esse.
>> Deixa eu só ver uma coisa aqui. Macaã.
Esse aqui é o é o único. Eu vou pegar o
Ah, o duplo eu deixei lá.
O outro eu deixei por engano.
Pega esse aqui, ó.
>> Aí tem que tirar do senhor
>> trouxe a caixinha errada, mas tá lá em
casa. Depois pego.
Tem a senha pra Andar.
>> Tu acha que dá fazer isso? conectar ali
mais longe.
>> É, eu vouar fora
para perguntar e
>> é que
e eu aquele duplo eu não tenho aqui, tá?
Eu deixei em casa hoje de manhã, eu
olhei o que que eu vou precisar.
>> É, eu acho também.
Pessoal, acho que não vão voltar não.
Meio-dia já.
Acho que eu vou fechar a sala.
Aí cada um faz sua dedicação de méritos.
Tá bom,
gente? Tô falando aqui.
Tchau.
Que os méritos desse encontro se
expandam e toquem a todos.
M.